Так ватажок ПВК "Вагнер" Євген Пригожин вже не вперше погрожував,
що відведе своїх найманців від Бахмута нібито через "снарядний голод"
і неможливість продовжувати військові дії.
У своїх відео він у всьому звинувачував Міноборони Росії, а саме Шойгу з Герасимовим.
Такі істеричні висловлювання Пригожина, на думку військового експерта Михайла Самуся,
не що інше як внутрішні російські розбірки між двома впливовими групами,
які боряться за ближче розташування до Путіна, щоб
отримати більше впливу і грошей.
Це проєкт ГРУ ГШ, тобто воєнної розвідки,
який поступово вийшов за межі контролю воєнної розвідки
і очевидно, що це став уже, в тому числі, комерційним проєктом кількох олігархів,
чи, скажімо так, впливових людей, які дотичні до Путіна особисто.
Тому, в принципі, Пригожин є просто спікером цієї групи людей,
які намагаються боротися в тому числі з іншою групою впливовою,
в яку ходить, наприклад, Шойгу, Герасимов і, як це не дивно, ФСБ,
які також беруть участь в цих розбірках.
Путін контролює обидві групи і йому вигідно, щоб вони конкурували одна з одною, а не проти нього.
Тому час від часу зіштовхує їх лобами.
Коли бачиш, як Пригожин біснується, сварить Шойгу,
то бачиш роздробленість, підкилимну боротьбу і мафіозні розбірки,
які характерні для вищого керівництва російської армії
і які пояснюють чи частково пояснюють той факт,
що російська армія далеко не друга найкраща армія у світі.
Зараз такою безперечно є українська армія,
і я думаю, що так буде й надалі.
Ви знаєте, відкрито видно, що у російській армії відсутнє єдине керівництво,
якесь єдине командування.
І це багато говорить про те, що собою представляє Росія
і особливо її військова кампанія за останні півтора роки або рік.
Формується ще більш жорстка диктатура на чолі з Путіним.
Він граючись, тобто не тільки він, звісно, а та група людей найближчих,
це КДБшники, які з ними ще служили в КДБ, вони вибудовують саме таку систему,
коли вони спочатку одну групу піднімають, потім її опускають, потім іншу.
Особливо, звісно, вони турбуються про те, щоб вони воювали або конкурували один з одним.
Тобто все це відбувається дуже класична КДБшна схема,
коли на цьому полі всіх цих груп впливу відбувається
боротьба одна з одною, а не, наприклад, вони домовляються
і борються проти Путіна і потім починають боротися за владу між собою.
Насправді ніякого "снарядного голоду" у вагнерівців не було і немає.
Їм вистачає боєприпасів, у них на озброєнні є авіація, артилерія, бронетехніка.
Проте найчастіше вони використовували штурмові загони для атаки українських позицій
і не рахувалися з втратами.
Унаслідок цього втратили кілька десятків тисяч бойовиків.
Пригожину просто перестало вистачати людей, і він почав думати варіанти, яким чином відійти.
А чому він мав відійти? Тому що він же досить багато говорив про те, що вагнерівці захоплять Бахмут.
І він навіть намагався встановлювати прапор, заявляти, а результату немає.
Відповідно, треба шукати відхідні шляхи. І він почав шукати виправдання в тому,
що він би цю задачу досяг, якби йому належним чином поставили все.
І почав звинувачувати Міноборони.
Тому ми в цьому не винні, ми робили все можливе, а от вони винні.
А ці в Міноборони зі свого боку подумали, що, знаєте, даруйте, немає дурних,
він хоче боєприпасів, ми дамо боєприпаси, хай продовжує воювати.
Спроба Пригожина "зіскочити" і відвести війська від Бахмута не спрацювала.
Так само як і захопити місто до 9 травня йому не вдалося.
Натомість він підтвердив, що з-під Бахмута втекла 72-га бригада РФ, оголивши фланги вагнерівців.
Їх вибила з позицій 3-тя окрема штурмова бригада зі складу "Азову",
яка ліквідувала понад сотню окупантів, знищила БК та техніку.
Та як довго це зможе тривати? Адже замінити вагнерівців наприклад кадирівцями -
не варіант, кажуть оглядачі, бо "тік-ток війська" Кадирова -
це лише воєнізована жандармерія, яка не може воювати.
Для Пригожина ця ситуація була дійсно шоу, в результаті якого йому вдалося уникнути запитання,
де перемога, де результати.
Очевидно, що він розуміє, не буде вже ніяких результатів,
тобто все наближається до активних дій української сторони,
українських Збройних Сил весною і літом.
І тому йому треба підготувати це підґрунтя,
тобто вони зараз зафіксуються десь на бахмутському напрямку
і почнуть демонструвати, що вони роблять все, що можна.
Але я думаю, що зусилля все ж таки будуть послаблятися поступово, особливо, коли Україна почне активні дії.
Тобто вони вже тоді точно, я думаю, що вони звідти будуть виводити війська.
Тобто вагнерівці не можуть стояти в обороні,
це штурмові м’ясні групи, які не можуть стояти і здійснювати оборону.
Вони просто будуть виводитися,
туди будуть заводитися регулярні сили вже мобілізовані,
які будуть забезпечувати оборону.
Сам Бахмут, за словами експертів, вже не має для росіян впливу
ані на тактичну, ані на стратегічну обстановку,
бо далі йдуть інші оборонні рубежі української армії.
Тому вони намагаються використовувати цей напрямок
лише для відтермінування українського контрнаступу.
Станом на зараз Бахмут для них важливий з точки зору того,
аби протидіяти підготовці до українського контрнаступу.
Я поясню, чому. Тому що якщо раніше можна було подивитися і побачити,
що роль Бахмута дійсно була з точки зору розвитку оперативного
і стратегічного успіху по захопленню всієї Донецької області
і виходу на Слов’янськ, Краматорськ, Костянтинівку,
то на сьогоднішній день роль зводиться до того,
що російські війська і російське командування думають,
що постійно підтримуючи наступальні дії в Бахмуті,
українські сили в свою чергу будуть вимушені туди перекидати резерви, відповідно, додаткові сили.
Та як наслідок, вони думають таким чином, що чим більше наших резервів піде туди, українських,
тим менше можна застосувати до контрнаступу,
чи тим більше буде часу потрібно для того, щоб підготувати додаткові сили.
Російські війська витратили дуже багато часу і ресурсів для того, щоб прорвати оборону на Донбасі.
А добитися переговорів, знищивши енергетичну інфраструктуру України
і "заморозивши" Європу без російського газу, їм не вдалося.
Тому тепер, на думку експертів, армії РФ доведеться переходити в оборону.
Звісно, вони намагаються збудувати оборонні рубежі на півдні,
але, насправді, це їм не допоможе.
Тобто, за цей час українська армія отримала нову зброю,
підготувала нові бригади,
зараз завершується формування взагалі тих бойових можливостей,
у тому числі далекобійних, високоточних, які стануть ключовими
при проведенні наступальних дій української армії.
І все це завдяки тому, що Росія застрягла на кількох оцих точках на Донбасі
і не змогла провести, наприклад, мобілізацію.
А Пригожину залишається хіба що їздити на кладовища,
показувати трупи вагнерівців та істерично кричати на відео,
що він зробив все, що міг, а у поразці винне лише Міноборони РФ.